sur le cas précis du brigadier-chef ben
mohamed celui ci a effectivement dénoncé
alors pardon de le dire mais c'est
exactement ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui à ma
connaissance avec retard c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'il vit un peu reproché
on en reparlera si vous le souhaitez de
dénoncer ses camarades
ces policiers qui auraient je mets du
conditionnel mais les faits sont
reprochés sont graves
énoncer des insultes à caractère sexiste
homophobe et raciste des maltraitance et
privation d'eau ou des refus de faire
venir un médecin ou d'aller aux
toilettes et de nombreux témoignages
corroboré les propos du brigadier chef
benoît m bon nous avons constaté alors
je le dis en continuité de l'état qu'un
rapport a été fait le 12 mars 2019 et
l'igpn a saisi le préfet de police le 6
juin 2019 l'igpn a relevé des
comportements tout à fait inapproprié de
la part de six fonctionnaires de police
injures agressivité mensonge
désobéissance je lis des termes utilisés
par l'inspection générale
elle a proposé bien avant la révélation
par l'article de presse d'hier à renvoi
devant le conseil de discipline avec 4
sanctions directes et une alternative
aux poursuites disciplinaires et dans
l'es4 sanctions directes
il y à aussi monsieur b nous amène
mohamed on aura l'occasion sans doute
d'en reparler c'est rare l'igpn a fait
13 préconisations et a demandé à la
préfecture de police de les mettre en
place pour mettre fin aux
dysfonctionnements constatés
j'ai constaté aujourd'hui que le parquet
de paris s'est dessaisi de d'une enquête
préliminaire concernant ces faits il
appartient donc pas de commenter une
enquête
une enquête de police ce qui est certain
c'est que si ces faits sont avérés il
m'appartiendra de savoir pourquoi les
préconisations du gpn ne sont pas encore
mis en place
vous avez raison de le dire pourquoi les
sanctions alors que ça fait une petite
une petite année une grosse année pardon
une grosse année 6 juin 2019 pour des
sanctions n'ont pas été prises elles
sont en cours at on dit et donc je
recevrai effectivement la patronne de
l'igpn pour en parler et vous avez mille
fois raison monsieur député il faut
savoir être juste moi je crois que la
quasi intégralité des policiers des
gendarmes
comme tous les corps de profession font
leur travail a difficilement avec
difficulté est qu'on doit les soutenir
s'il existe quelques agents
qui ont sali l'uniforme de la république
qui n'ont plus rien à faire dans la
police de la république
voilà je peux le dire autrement et
j'aurai l'occasion d'en reparler si vous
le souhaitez même si la procédure
judiciaire
effectivement et est en cours